Yeah.
What did you think about all that stuff getting leaked?
Well Louise,
you know,
stop stand up at a really good point about that.
But what does he say,
Doug?
You were saying like,
look,
if this was a movie and if you took that movie and filmed it in the movie
theater and then put it online,
you'd be,
you'd go to jail.
You're a criminal,
you're stealing,
you're exposing your,
you're ruining his work.
Yes.
But they think they can ruin his work cause he jerked off in front of some
people.
I don't even know if it's that,
I don't even know if the person that lake it like was a Louis Hater sometimes he
was a fan.
They were laughing hard.
Yes.
It's like they had to phone in their table.
I was at,
it wasn't governors,
it was the brokerage,
which is the same owners few years ago.
And I'm up there doing my shit and working on a new hour.
I looked on and the kid about 56 row,
I see him,
I see the red light.
Yeah.
And he's got his head down.
So I come down off the stage.
He doesn't even hear me.
And I grabbed the phone out of his hand.
Ah,
deleted.
I go,
dude,
you came out because you're a fan of mine.
Right.
I go,
the problem,
I explained it to him and the whole crowd.
The problem with this is if you put this shit online,
I'm working on news,
that's old material.
You're burning my shit.
You get it to all the other fans that listen to it for sure.
And also it's not fair because these bits are never done.
Like if you want to release it half baked,
like when when you first start working on a bit,
you have a premise,
you got kind of an idea where it's gone course.
Yeah.
And then it eventually becomes a bit that you would put on a special,
right?
Yeah.
And they'd get it halfway or a quarter in that and it'll look shitty and it's
all if it's done,
if you're doing a bit that's complete.
Yeah.
They,
it becomes old without some of the things that people were saying about Louie,
that the material's sloppy.
It's not like his old stuff.
Yeah.
He's working shit on the old stuff you saw when it was done.
Like if you came to the store and saw him working on a set like a few years
back,
you would see the same kind of stuff.
I got a couple of comments like that when I put my last special out there.
Like,
well he's doing the same stuff.
I well you came out to see me eight,
10 months ago when I was working on it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
something in process.
They don't understand though.
Cause it seems like when you're onstage and you can't went up to toppy buggin
hit and it seems like you're doing something that they can do.
You're just talking,
oh I know you just talk and I could talk.
He's like,
there's no other art form like that where it's just talking.
That's exactly right.
Nobody yells at a concert,
nobody should go that fucking,
you know,
I could play bass better.
That jerk off.
I May,
but it stand up.
So
people have,
you know,
because people have made their friends laugh.
I think Seinfeld saw it in a book years ago because you know you make your
friends laugh,
everybody's made their friends laugh with a comic and I and you like all the I
can do.
I call people out when they look bored with me or they had their arms folded.
I go do it.
You've got that smug look on your face.
I know you could do this too,
but you'd rather work at the fucking mattress factory 80 hours a week and making
fucking $400 there's people out there working at the mattress factory right now
listening to this going,
man,
fuck you nuke Dick.
Go fuck them.
Whoa.
Hey,
how about you just ignore the guy that's a $2,000 for a mattress.
You can weird.
Well,
I know like a mattress.
How much can I pay you to make a mattress?
I don't know.
What am I getting it from?
Comedy Palace in San Diego.
I have to pay you a lot of money to build me a mattress
but keep,
but you said
you have to pay for the phone.
Ditch it all together.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You can make it a mattress.
Be Easy places.
I get farm laying all over the house.
Start with my wife's boobs.
Oh,
come on Joe.
Where'd he get this coffee?
It's fucking delicious.
Good.
Where?
I think this is black rifle.
Black rifle off that name.
It's a racist.
Oh,
it's not gun metal.
It's a company of veterans.
That makes sense.
You got coffee equals veteran owned.
Fuck yeah.
Matt flags veteran on to confess your own company.
I get a flag.
They sent me a,
when I did the Afghanistan USL think guy sent me a flag that they used in
battle.
Nice.
You have it folded up and I had it hanging,
but then I made a gym out of my fucking whatever.
So I don't know where it is.
Wow.
We should probably find it.
I should probably put it back up.
So I brought that up.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
the Louis C K set,
you know,
was very similar in my opinion,
to all the shit that he did before he got in trouble.
But very slowly,
very similar.
Same kind of material,
the same way he does things.
I mean,
people forget that this is a guy who went on Saturday night live and did a joke
about pedophilia,
pedophiles and about,
you know,
maybe we should like let them get away with it so they don't kill your kids.
I mean there's,
it's fucked up.
It's a fucked up bit.
But he was the darling of the left back then and so then he allowed to get away
with that if he tried to do that same material.
If he hadn't done that then and instead did that,
now people would be fucking horrified.
What is it Joe,
about offending women or today's feminist?
What they're,
they are at the,
in my opinion,
all this political correctness that we hate so much down they are at the core,
but,
well,
p did the,
I say this,
the,
the Zeitgeists of the times,
it's like a fat chicks emotion.
Well,
very sensitive.
You can't,
you can't cross them.
But it's also because people are realizing now that they can make an impact.
Like one of the things that I read because he's doing this thing in Pittsburgh.
He was doing the Improv in Pittsburgh and this lady who wrote the article wrote
that he's making people put their cell phones in bags.
Much like comedians,
Dave Chappelle and Joe Rogan do.
She used my name to,
I've done it before but I only did it when I was filling with my Netflix
special,
so I didn't want people putting the material out or right before I was releasing
the special and then afterwards I decided it was too much of a pain in the ass,
but the only reason why I was doing it,
w w it had nothing to do with this.
She said because they know words can offend.
They don't want the consequences.
Well,
I'm going to put it on Netflix anyways.
It's going to be out to the public.
It's offensive.
It's good.
If you're looking to get offended,
go watch Netflix special.
There's plenty in there for you,
but I need to be able to do it correctly.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I want to work it out so that it has the maximum amount of laughs with a minimum
amount of people getting it the wrong way.
Right.
So this,
it's all about wording and sitting upright and listening to it and go,
maybe there's a better way and you can't do that if somebody releases your shit.
And so these people that don't know comedy and they're saying this like you have
no idea what the process is like,
you just don't.
And if you,
if you do,
you would respect it and appreciate it.
And the people that are comics that don't respect and appreciate the process,
like that's where we are now.
But it's just because people can make an impact.
It can have a reaction just like the people yelling at her,
you know,
that that she said,
she said,
oh my grandmother would be rolling over in her grave up say day in them,
say in them,
they're just trying to get a reaction from you.
They're just trying to push buttons.
They're just knowing that they can say something and they can have some sort of
an impact.
We're going to get Louis C K band from here.
You know,
we're going to get nick depalo kicked out of this club.
You can't come to this club.
You've talked negatively about women and women's empowerment,
and that's dangerous to girls.